[Applause]
[Music]
well welcome everyone to this
intelligent squared debate I'm really
delighted uh to be taking part in this
not least because I have such mixed
feelings on the
subject I am forever tweeting pictures
of misplaced apostrophes and the like
and yet I think language is a living
thing and clearly we are not all still
talking or writing like Cher or whoever
whomever
whatever and yet such was my delight
when in an episode of Doctor Who John
Sim as the master ordered decimate them
destroy one in every
10 no one gets decimate right anymore we
have to count on aliens for that Bravo
as to disinterested versus uninterested
well I'm sure our panel will Enlighten
us as to their thoughts on the subject
now um I just want to remind you that
you will be casting your vote at the end
of the evening you should have one of
these a ticket um and you will tear it
in two and then you vote with either the
for or against if you're still undecided
which I find pretty hard to believe um
but you might be um you put the whole uh
ticket into The Ballot Box now I have a
little question before we start just
we're all curious given the mix um of
intelligent squared audience I
wonder how many people raise your hand
if English is not your first language if
you are a non so we have a good A
Generous sprinkling 40 50 people people
so that would be very interesting to
know um what you think of our panelists
and our
debate so I am going to start by
introducing our first Speaker who is a
BBC Radio 4 today presenter this is your
cue to rise from your
chair they did
tell
he is the author of Lost for Words the
mangling and manipulating of the English
language and beyond words how language
reveals the way we live now and you have
already welcomed John humph but do it
again that second bit of Applause
doesn't come out of my a lotted time
does it no no that's all right
now right we're starting now I want to
start with a story um a short story
about a young very poor unsophisticated
black American kid from The Deep South
who was very clever and he won a
scholarship to Harvard University went
to Harvard on his first day there
wandering around the campus and he saw a
couple of extremely sophisticated um
Harvard students standing leaning
against a war non on it with their
Kashmir sweaters and scarves and all
arrested and he approached them and said
hey all can you tell me where the lab is
at and they looked at him with disdain
and one of them said old man at Havard
we tend not to end sentences with
prepositions so he looked he looked back
up at them and he said uh C can you tell
me where the library is at
now I I tell that story well
partly for the cheap laugh but also and
mainly because I want to show that those
of us who support this motion are not
necessarily pedants because what that
young man did was brilliant his English
was magnificent it was forthright direct
entirely unambiguous it was entertaining
it did everything that is required he
was communicating magnificently but
here's the point you cannot communicate
he also knew how to do it in other ways
of course because he was a clever kid
you can't communicate without a basic
understanding of certain rules and we
like to call it grammar doesn't matter
what you call it anybody here learned a
second language lots of you I dare say
did you do it without having some
understanding of the grammar of that of
course you didn't I left school at the
age of 15 and I hated school I was
hopeless at it thick as two short planks
but I did learn a little bit about
grammar enough to enable me to pen a
sort of reasonable sentence I think
anyway I applied for a job the local
paper at the age of 15 got it and it's
been downhill ever since it worked for
me shortly after I left school the
educationists i' prefer to call them
ideologues um decided that they would
abolish the teaching of grammar in our
schools because they said it was uh in
it was it was closing in students it was
locking them into this sort of dead man
dead white man's language structure and
there was absolutely no need for it what
we had to do was let their imaginations
run free we didn't want to constrict
them with rules which of course was
exactly the opposite of what happens
when you teach kids grammar if you have
grammar it's a tool it enables you to
put sentences together it enables you to
communicate deprive them of that they
cannot communicate as well as they
should so they stopped doing it few
years later I was writing a column for
the Sunday Times and uh got a huge
response to it about this particular
subject got a huge response had a letter
from a mother who sent me an essay that
her uh young daughter had written she
was 10 years old and the essay had been
marked by the teacher at the bottom of
it the teacher had said very nice but
you could have written this a lot neater
now if I were a real pedant I would have
said what a lot neater you're using an
adjective when you should be using an
adverb with terrible English no what
made me just slightly upset about it was
you could have written she had written
of for have yeah indrawn breath and
absolute what
chance what chance did that poor kid
have she didn't her teacher didn't know
the difference between of and have for
God's sake but
there's look Erica has already made the
point that that we shouldn't try to
preserve English and aspic absolutely
not I love it absolutely love it I've
got a 13-year-old I've also got kids up
to the age of 47 which is why I look so
old my youngest is 14 and he speaks
often with his friends nearly 14 a
language that I can't understand and I
think that's absolutely wonderful it
shows that they're alive to language
they're inventing we've all done it as
kids haven't we I mean now they use the
word sick to mean pretty good wonderful
whatever ever whereas we might have used
the word cool well I mean cool was
stupid sick is stupid but it's alive the
language is living and I don't care if
Shakespeare has banio um split
infinitives I don't care when el el
docto gives Billy Bathgate the sort of
grammar that would utterly unacceptable
in any respectable forum and he doesn't
observe the rules of punctuation and so
on doesn't matter he's alive he's
speaking as Billy Bathgate on the
streets of of Brooklyn years and years
and years and years ago and its Dynamic
it's wonderful English that's art but
what we have language for primarily is
what an obvious thing I'm about to say
is to communicate and you do it by using
the sort of phrasing the sort of
sentences that make people feel at ease
when they know where you're going they
know the point you're making you if
you're reasonably confident at it they
will be unambiguous now grammar
structure is one thing vocabulary is
another and this is one of the things
that does worry me a bit and I looked at
a few of the words we've already heard a
couple of Erica mentioned the um
disinterested well it's different from
uninterested and it's a good and
important word we've lost it infer is
different from imply another important
distinction we've lost it we also and
this worries me rather more we
substitute weak words I know why this is
going on here I suspect it's it's for
political reasons politically correct
reasons you might even say um we
substitute weak words for strong words
so just a couple of examples we don't
have you know we don't have problems any
longer we have issues
issues around things we don't have
difficulties any longer we have
challenges hardworking is a phrase we
can no longer use because according to
our politicians every family in the land
unless they're actually on the Dole and
begging in the gutter is a hardworking
family it's gone it's denied to us and I
say politicians and this is the point
look this is why one of the reasons why
we need language and we need it to be
clear and and ambiguous because because
if we don't it becomes meaningless when
politicians employ the tricks that they
do we have we have to be aware of the
tricks that they play politics democracy
demands clear unambiguous communication
between us the ruled and them the rulers
Orwell obviously knew a thing or two
about this when he created new speak he
recognized that totalitarian regimes
have to control what we think and the
best way to do that is to try to control
the language so removed for new speak
they removed all those words from the
language that they were they did did not
want the population to use very
effective at least it might have been
ifed wor we don't know perhaps it'll be
tried again actually I say that they are
trying it in a way Gordon Brown did um
did a a budget speech at a time when
they were spending rather a lot of our
money they were at the height of the
spending speed and he delivered himself
of a budget speech in which he used the
word
spending twice he used the the word
investing 43 times now do you think he
was trying to deliver a message Tony
Blair made a magnificent speech I was
there in 2000 a party a party um
conference speech in which he delivered
himself and I wrote the figure down
because I got it from my old friend
Simon hoger sadly
deceased 163 of his sentences contained
no verb
now you
you you might say you might say that
doesn't matter very much but actually it
does cuz I tell you when you were in the
hall and you were listening to it you
were thinking great star hope B
achievement bom b boom the future not
the past what the hell does that mean
the future time
anyway and then when you sat down and
thought about it 10 minutes later you
realized it said buger all which may or
may not be good English the point is
verb cement meaning and what the
politicians want us to do is to take
their meaning without them having to be
explicit so it's different saying we
want prosperity for all and this is how
we're going to deliver it as opposed to
just saying Prosperity or one nation how
are you going to do it BBC I'd like to
say the BBC is entirely faultless in
this I'd like to say that we communicate
always unambiguously always clearly I
will give you a few little examples I
don't suppose I have very much time left
but I'll give you a few little examples
I dug these out for for my first book
actually um of where we allow just a
teeny weeny bit of um uh lack of
ambiguity let's put it let's creep in
these are from news bulletins for the
second time in 6 months a prisoner at
Durham jail has died after hanging
himself then
again and a another one a suicide bomber
has struck again in
Jerusalem we have we have one minute one
minute 60 women have come forward to say
they were assaulted by a dead
gynecologist one wonders what he might
have done had he been
alive rather rather more seriously there
was an appalling atrocious assault by a
gang of men on a shopping center in
Kenya in Nairobi last year you'll
remember it very well we went a great
length to describe these men as gunmen
extreme islamists whatever whatever
whatever we didn't use the word
terrorists for a number of days now what
those men did was they murdered children
in front of their mothers mothers in
front of their children they murdered
people for the express purpose of
creating Terror now if that is not a
definition of a terrorist I'm damned if
I know what is and my point is if we shy
away from words that we feel might cause
a bit of offense might jolt people a bit
if we if we try to um find
euphemisms then it's a dangerous road to
go down we're not exactly where Orwell
was but we're kind of taking those
little tiny tiny little baby steps
towards that unhealthy um State of
Affairs and that's what I want to do and
that's what Simon want that's what we
want to do we want we don't care
particularly about between you and I
that's just stupid and everybody knows
it's stupid and why would you say it
when you can say between you and me
pleas wrap it up what oh sorry hey I
want extra time now because you just
interrupted me cuz I wouldn't interrupt
anybody I can tell you
that but look what you are you're
actually going to hear from Mary in a
minute um and you're going to hear from
Oliver and you will be impressed by what
they have to say I'm telling you that I
know that because I've read Oliver in
the times I've seen Mary on the tally
and they are wonderful at what they do
and why is
that because they communicate with you
brilliantly they use the language
perfectly they are masters of the
language they know the rules they know
how to make it work so really what I'm
going to say to you is if you approve of
what they
say you vote for us
obviously and
uh as uh as as as an old uh former
presenter of radio for programs used to
say at the end of every one of them
somewhat I accept pedantically if you
have been thanks for
[Applause]
listening and now I would like to
welcome our first Speaker against the
motion commentator at the Times who
writes a weekly column ironically called
the pedant and all author of The
forthcoming accidents will happen a
guide to Modern English usage please
welcome the freestanding Oliver
cam thanks very much Erica ladies and
gentlemen there is one thing that John
and Simon and I have in common despite
our disagreements I don't want to be
personal let alone gracious about this
but we are not
young and this isn't an incidental
detail it is fundamental to this
debate in life in George Elliott's
magnificent construction the middle-aged
are a natural priesthood of Those whom
life has consecrated and disciplined to
be a refuge to early
stumblers but in this field in
linguistic use usage it's not like that
at
all people like
us are
querulous we insist on certain
essentially arbitrary designations and
rules and we get extremely cross when we
see them
flouted or some might say
flaunted and this isn't really a debate
about language at all it isn't it's it's
a debate about an almost
inconceivably minute subset of disputed
usages things such as disinterested
imply and infer uh the use of the
apostrophe this is compared with the
great potential of language an
astonishingly limited subset of usages
and disputed is the word if there were
no disagreement if there were an
obviously right body of rules as John
implies then there would be a need for
only one style manual and we would all
be taught taught from it it isn't like
that at all language is
interesting language is about the way
and on this point I do agree with John
is about the way human societies
communicate every human society has
complex grammatical constructions it has
language language is the way that we
have uh the ability to replicate ideas
we don't need to invent everything a new
every
time language is in the phrase of uh
Steven Pinker the cognitive scientist in
a great book it's an instinct the
language Instinct by which he means not
that English toddlers have an instinct
for English grammar and Japanese
toddlers have an instinct for
Japanese grammar but every small child
every three-year-old says Pinker is a
grammatical genius is a master of
complex grammatical constructions I
quoted this judgment in one of my
columns once and a times reader wrote to
me to say if you think every
three-year-old is a grammatical genius
well you haven't met my grandchildren
now they have turned into teenagers and
of course he was missing the point he
was in in in he was assuming that
certain slang terms such as John
referred to are evidence of linguistic
debasement but every three-year-old can
say faultlessly and you will have heard
it many times I want an ice cream it's
an astonishingly complex construction of
pronoun verb and noun phrase in object
case every child learns it every child
out in the park sees a canine says doggy
sees two kind canine says doggies that
child has leared by Instinct that there
is a rule where a noun inflects for
number by adding s that's interesting
the sort of things that you find usage
pundits talk about is not interesting
it's an incredibly narrow subset of
usages which exemplify certain
fallacies another fallacy is that we're
talking about grammar linguists when
they talk about grammar mean usually
either syntax how words and phrases fit
together or morphology how words are
constructed the sort of things you read
about
in usage pundits columns and style
guides are not these things at all they
tend to be semantics the meanings of
words whether disinterested means bored
or whether it means impartial or
orthography that is spelling and
punctual ation the conventions of use of
the apostrophe are not some inviolable
rule of language they were imported from
from French in the period of early
modern English the conventions of the
use of the apostrophe so that it with an
apostrophe is an elision and not a
possessive that's purely arbitrary it
came about because it as an illusion was
already
taken in uh 18th century English the
green grosses apostrophe was absolutely
standard you will find references to
handles operas Opera apostrophe s these
are not John these are not rules of
grammar these are conventions of usage
yes we need conventions of usage but
they're nothing to do with logic they
are like um electrical points and
standards for fitting them they are just
tacit conventions that we find useful
certainly it is important that children
be taught the conventions of Standard
English but the reason that grammar
broadly defined not technically defined
the reason that grammar broadly defined
uh fell into abeyance in classrooms in
this country in the 1960s was not some
Progressive Revolution it was because
the content of those lessons was largely
rubbish these lessons were taken from
18th century Grim marians people like
Robert Baker Robert La Lindley Murray
who crops up in uh George Elliot quite a
lot um people who believed that there
was a set body of rules or rather that
there wasn't and that there ought to be
and they ought to Define it and these
rules were beaten literally beaten into
generations of school children to no
good effect I get letters every week
from times readers who I know were
educated
um in this era um who asked me if such
and such a rule still exist split
infinitives or whatever and my answer to
them is always no it doesn't and no it
never did split infinitives is a 19th
century the prohibition on split
infinitives is a 19th century
Superstition we can date it exactly it
comes from the 1830s English doesn't
even have an infinitive it has a
subordinator the word to and an
infinitival form split infinitives are
what everyone can spot and have nothing
to do with good English yet this is the
sort of stuff that appeared again and
again in so-called grammar lessons and
what the style pundits the usage pundits
continually confuse is stylistic
preference which we all have with rules
with grammar as John puts it not in fact
grammar at all just a set of arbitrary
edicts and prejudices yes it's important
that children learn the conventions of
Standard English but every native
English speaker already knows English
grammar it's absolutely absurd to say
you learn a second language in such and
such a way therefore you must learn a
first language in such and such a way
you already know the conventions of
English grammar because of the Instinct
that you have to learn a set of rules it
may not be though in the case of this
audience it almost certainly is the case
that it's Standard English but it may
not be with other native speakers
Standard English but it is grammatical
English complex grammatical
constructions the pedants the grammar
purists the sticklers they are hung up
on the idea that a language has certain
inviolable meanings and single
meanings and you can't ever change them
in fact no English speaker no English
speaker um adopts a purely consistent
approach that the origins of a word
determine its meaning language doesn't
work like that language doesn't work
like that and if you look up as
sticklers almost never do the history of
words such as enormity which Simon
refers to in his book when it came into
the language it did mean something of
huge size not just something um of great
wickedness Oliver yes thank you just
checking the problem with the stick 's
case I think comes down to
this the English-speaking world has
hugely expanded over the past Century
there are more non-native speakers than
there are native speakers British
Society has changed radically over the
last century over the last generation in
my view almost entirely for the good we
are a Freer more tolerant more polyglot
uh nation and
society and if you look at what the
sticklers insist upon they want an
Arcadia they want a golden society that
never existed um they believe that there
is one form of language that needs to be
taught they don't tolerate ambiguity as
John was very clear about yet ambiguity
is shot through the English language is
shot through with ambiguity it is not
essential to communication that we be
absolutely unambiguous because English
is a river it flows through many
tributaries and the stickers's argument
against is simply misguided and mistaken
it doesn't understand custom and ladies
and gentlemen I've had enough of
[Applause]
it well this is definitely a debate that
goes where no debate has gone
before um and uh bold indeed and um I'm
now going to introduce our third speaker
who is for the motion journalist on The
Daily Mail an author of strictly English
the correct way to write and why it
matters so please welcome Simon
[Applause]
heer thank you very much Erica ladies
and gentlemen um in the book that Eric
has just said kindly plugged uh it
sequels coming out in May by the way
said please order it now um I rail
against many things uh much I know to
all of's distaste uh but two of the
things I ra against particularly are the
use of cliche and the use of hyperbole
um obviously whoever framed the motion
this evening didn't read the book um I
think the the use of the nominative for
an accusative was was an attempt at
humor something I also warn against in
the book
um
I want to congratulate Oliver on his
speech I I I agreed much more than I
thought I was going to and I was
particularly Charmed by his use of a
subjunctive after about five minutes um
uh in both of the books uh that I've
written about grammar uh I have talked
about the structive and the importance
of it uh as one of the precision tools
that we can use in our language and I'm
afraid I look at language not just from
a utilitarian point of view although
that's very important as I shall say in
a moment but from an aesthetic point of
view um I'm the possessor of one of the
most useless things in the world a
degree in English from Cambridge
University and uh I read chorer I read
Milton and I know very well that our
language has evolved and only an idiot
and despite appearances I hope I'm not
quite in that class would stand up here
and say that our language must be frozen
of course words have changed their
meaning and of course grammar has
evolved since cha was writing since
Milton was writing even since Charles
Dickens was writing and we all accept
that things change people change new
inventions come along that require new
words none of us had heard 40 years ago
of a fact machine uh so of course
language has to change but I take this
rather old-fashioned View and I
apologize for being oldfashioned that
there was a movement towards the end of
the 19th century both in terms of words
and grammar where an attempt was made to
codify our Lang language I forbear to
say uh that people try to set rules um
that's for others to interpret but there
was an attempt to codify the
language and you had from 1880 onwards
actually I think before that the the the
the program to produce what was
originally called the new English
dictionary Assumption of the Oxford
English Dictionary uh it's a a point
that words do change their meaning that
the OED uh had supplements and then had
a second edition and I believe a third
edition is now under way and anybody who
wants to consult the OED most valuably
does so by looking online because words
change all the time I have certain beefs
with Oxford University press for example
um John actually was Oliver who talked
about the difference between flaunt and
flout I was first aware of uh this
catris um on The Today program it wasn't
John of course who did it it was um
somebody who was being interviewed about
a football match and uh that we wanted
to dealing stereotypes here you
understand and uh this man said yeah
well of course tra was uh the trouble
was Kevin that you know he was he was
flaunting the rules all over the place
and
I I was incredibly shocked by this and
and I I'm easily shocked before
breakfast believe
me I rushed to the uh manuscript of
strictly English available from all good
book sellers but quite cheap on Amazon
and I entered this uh particular mistake
into uh into the book I then went to the
Oxford English Dictionary to make sure
that I was correctly using both flaunt
and flut because even Homer nods
occasionally and I saw when I looked up
flaunt it said uh occasionally used for
flout it it it didn't say it's wrong
perhaps that's not the oed's job but it
said it was there and by putting it
there and not saying it was wrong I felt
this misuse of the English language was
being endorsed after all these are two
words that are one syllable one is six
letters one is five it's not too
difficult even I would have thought for
the meanest of intellects to work out
that one means to parade something and
the other means to show disregard for
something and I worry why it is that we
fetishize in this country the abuse of
our language we are a nation that is
almost constantly in a cultural cringe
towards many of our European neighbors
we we think that the French have better
looking women than we have that the
Germans have better composers than we
have uh we the Italians have a better
Cuisine than we have we look at foreign
countries and we Envy them and we feel
that they do things so much better than
we do
but in fact the one thing that we don't
emulate in foreign countries is there is
there almost militaristic obsession with
teaching their languages properly I used
to have a French conversation class
every week um I when I worked at the
Daily Telegraph I was attempting to
cover French politics and uh my French
was pretty rudimentary and a very sweet
woman came in from King's College London
every Tuesday evening and uh talked to
me in French and I struggled and tried
to talk back to her and she would become
almost vicious she was the nicest woman
imaginable she would become almost
vicious with me if I did not uh Godless
subun she said you should use a
subjunctive there she said a child of 11
in a French school would use a
subjunctive there you clot and I
felt utterly
humiliated and I presume because of
Oliver's own Precision with the
subjunctive he's had the same teacher at
some
stage but we don't think badly of the
French we think of banded French for
many reasons but not
but but not for that reason not that
they are so peculiar about their
language I wouldn't want to go so far as
to have an academy as the French it
would I it's really silly and is one of
the things that we can be you poke fun
out about the French but we should take
an aesthetic pride in using the
Precision Tool of our language properly
now I wanted to come on to utility
because utilitarianism I'm afraid does
wear its ugly head I used to recruit
graduate trainees for the Daily
Telegraph and I worked there and we used
to get about a thousand applicants uh
every year for five or six places on The
Graduate training scheme and uh the
people in uh HR I believe that's a
cliche but you know what I mean uh the
the the people in HR some of whom could
actually read and write were
asked to look at these thousand
applications and to reject any that
included either on the application form
or in the covering letter a spelling
mistake or a grammatical
uh my grounds for that were quite simple
I wasn't discriminating against anybody
I took the view that we already had
enough semi literates on the paper as it
was
and I I didn't think it was a good idea
to hire anymore now Oliver has talked
about times readers writing to him I
used to have ending up on my desk the
quite folic letters of telegraph readers
for whom an outbreak of war was was
little compared with not the splitting
of an infinitive but a a hanging Clause
um or or or a a plural where there
should have been a singular and vice
versa and I would Whittle down or my
colleagues would Whittle down this slew
of 11 1200 applicants some year to
around 200 and these were all we only
advertise at what is known as the best
universities uh and at the best
universities they were supplying us with
these people when it came to the short
listing there was a boy who was a very
very bright boy indeed he had a double
fur
from Cambridge which is more than I ever
achieved and so I I instinctively
deferred to him and respected him and we
made him come back with the other 12
people other 11 people on the short list
to do a spelling test uh they were
supplied with the 45 hardest words to
spell in the English language and the
other 11 candidates got between 35 and
45 which I thought was commendable you
know we we can't all be perfect um this
boy with his double first got I think 18
or 19 and and I was rather
shocked uh I presumed he had used a
spell check for his application uh he
obviously had some native cunning I one
got into Cambridge in the first place
and I was distressed and I was on a
sabatical at the time at my college at
Cambridge and the next day I said to the
very brilliant Dawn who taught English
is it possible to get a double first in
English at this supposedly great
University without an ability to spell
and she said well of course it is now
that has changed in the 30 years since I
was an undergraduate because I'm pretty
certain that I would have got a third
class degree or a special or something
really Grim like that if I had been
unable to spell I wasn't just being
tested on my knowledge of Jane Austin or
my ability to um work out what
Shakespeare's metaphors meant I think I
was being tested on an ability to
communicate and it was it was manifest
to me that the debauchery of our
education system in the last 30 years
has stopped people from communicating I
when I brought out strictly English I
was attacked by various professional
linguists who said huh you know don't
make up rules like that you know
whatever whatever anybody says goes it's
all fine it's a free-for all and I agree
with John you know young people are um
are fully entitled to speak English as
they wish and to communicate among
themselves uh in whatever way they see
possible but when the moment comes when
you actually apply for a job or apply
for a place at a good University and you
don't get that place at the University
or you don't get that job because you
can't write English properly it's all
very well for um a professor um sitting
I don't mean Mary in this case because
she wouldn't dream of being so ignorant
but I I don't um I don't think it's very
good for a professor um who has made his
way to the top um to sit and say it's
all very well for other people to speak
English badly when he's got a job and
he's got a security in his life and
young people are failing because many of
us do still speak English people buy
books like mine and like Olivers and
they buy them because they're interested
in maintaining that Precision Tool and
they don't like people who don't respect
the language all I'm asking for is to
respect the language I'm sure it isn't
really going to the dogs but it's there
is a climate where we fetishize the bad
use of English it's not big and it's not
clever and I urge you
to yes I heard you to support the motion
thank
you
[Applause]
and now please welcome our final speaker
against the motion professor of Classics
at Cambridge University television
broadcaster and author of the widely
read blog adon's life in which she
comments on worlds both ancient and
modern Professor Mary
[Applause]
beard
uh well I'm at a disadvantage here
because I'm the only amateur on the
panel um my Ally Oliver writes a column
about little naughty problems of
language and the BLS at the other end of
both written books about this you know
they're the kind of guys who go home at
night we have to imagine and enjoy
discussing with their Partners whether
disinterested is different from
uninterested
Ed they get up in the morning and unless
they're John they listen to the today
program and they get they get cross
about flouting flaunting flaunting the
rules without realizing the poor guy was
making a joke wasn't he Simon just
missed the joke anyway um I'm here as
the classicist uh amateur and I suppose
you would think that possibly um a woman
who was really brought up on um Latin
grammar from the age of about 11 would
perhaps be on their side of the debate
but I'm not and I feel actually
intelligence squar brings out the sort
of dissident in me because last time I
was here I found myself a lefty
defending the right of the public
schools to exist and here I am saying
that the English language is not going
to the dogs why I'm saying that is
because um I I've got a foot in two
camps really because I think I'm a
reformed pedant you know they're pedants
but I'm a kind of recovering pedant
recovering
alcoholic um and I'm reformed in this
sense and as I said um I was brought up
on grammar I was brought up more on
Latin grammar uh than English grammar um
and I learned and devoured all the rules
and exceptions to particular forms of
Latin usage that we were very expertly
if rather ruthlessly taught I mean I
don't know how many people in the room
um actually suffered some of this but I
remember learning things like you use in
and that's the Latin for in you use in
with the ative case unless you're
talking about a town or a small island
in which case you use the locative case
and I remember thinking how small does
the island have to be before you know
whether to use the locatif or not but
anyway I got off on this I have to say
and that's really because I think I was
a bit of a control freak in my teens and
my 20s and Latin was a great language
whose practice and principles uh you
could lay out and you could control or
obey uh and you could you know you could
write it down and tabulate it uh and I
still think there's something fun about
that but it was only in my 30s when I'd
been in a university job for some time
that I discovered what is the horrible
but in some ways truly liberating truth
that is to say Latin grammar that I'd
spent such a long time learning
believing it to be a a deeply Ro form
was actually something that had been
invented by Germans in the 19th
century who had looked at all the Latin
there was they could find and they tried
to make the rules they didn't completely
actually succeed in making the rules and
that's why there were all those
exceptions because the exceptions were
the things that the Germans couldn't
actually make fit their otherwise
brilliant
scheme and I saw that as soon as I
looked at anything that was actually
written by a real Roman uh and I mean
not something that was Rewritten for
them by a 19th century German they were
breaking the rules all the time and that
Latin was different across the centuries
and those exceptions were the rules they
weren't the exceptions and just to go to
John's point about poal Mr Blair not
using any not using enough verbs in his
speeches there was no end a Roman orus
Cicero was always leaving out the verbs
youed to say the verb here is understood
that means there wasn't a verb in the
sentence you can have sentences without
verbs in Latin it's
wonderful anyway it wasn't a long way
from there it wasn't a great distance
from that realization about the fatuity
of Latin grammar to uh the position I'm
now in where I find myself embracing and
cherishing the kind of changes and
Innovations that's what they are we see
are in modern linguistic usage and I
find myself thinking that if English
were to be going to the dogs which I
don't believe it to be doing the people
responsible for it going to the dogs are
those guys not me and Oliver
right the ones who are kind of seem to
me whatever their disavowal about how
they like kids saying I'm good and all
the rest actually seem to be bent on
preserving distinctions in the language
that no longer particularly uh useful to
us they also the other thing they do
late at night I think they can never
actually agree about the rules so they
have you know even though they want to
uphold the rules they don't know what
they are because they'll go on for ages
about should you start a sentence with
the word and you know and they disagree
about this so I guess I have come to
relish change and to relish difference
and subversion and linguistic rry I'm
pleased that we don't much have an
accusative case in the English language
now you know I'm very glad that we don't
go around talking about thou and Thee I
find things like Finnigan's Wake are
absolutely enriching and I'm hugely
delighted that words change their
meaning that we have new distinctions
that we want to draw and I think that's
fun and interesting and it has a
historical depth to it I remember the
first time that I read Jane Austin just
to give you one example the other way
around I can't remember which one it was
but Mr somebody was in the drawing room
with Miss somebody and it said they were
making love in front of the fire and I
thought blim
me making love in front and eventually
after they' done this several times you
know in public um I realized it just
meant flirt right now nobody's saying
here that there are no rules to language
and that anybody like me is throwing
them away there's no social activity in
the world that doesn't have rules I mean
none of you have come this evening in
your bathing costumes you know we have
rules of costume of demeanor and
department and
language but actually what rules enable
us to do is to break them to avow
different ones to debate what they
should be and actually to transcend the
damn things and it seems to me that the
most authoritative and independent and
enriching language users are those who
know the rules you know you don't start
a job application hi mate you know that
wouldn't be you know in Simon's terms
not a great idea but they have a
sufficient grip that they can uh
overturn subvert them and make the
language do new new things because the
bottom line is this language is ours
it's not you know it doesn't own us we
own it and we want to use it to do new
jobs
so um what I suppose I wondered is where
does it leave these two BLS on the other
side now at certain point I felt that
John was should have been on our side
anyway I didn't think he really belonged
with Simon
um um you know in other words look at
them and I think they're a wonderful
example of what I'm trying not to say
but I'm going to uh the traditional
English grumpy old man you know who've
been around forever saying oh it's not
the same now there were Roman there were
Roman Grumpy Old Men too you know who
said people aren't using in with the
abative properly I guess um they've been
around for centuries um but I think in
that way they're rather valuable to us I
mean I like to have them there as a as
an example of of to keep us on our toes
but not necessarily to follow they're a
useful reminder of what you might do
with a language if you were just that
little bit well-meaning but
misguided that's where I want to keep
them uh I think the key is to love them
cherish them not to vote for them let me
say that would be a very great mistake
don't believe all that they say when
heer tells me in his book that collide
comes from the Latin collider and you
can only ever use it of two moving
objects therefore you can't Collide into
a tree I tell you he's just wrong
right prove it but yeah kering means
bruise in Latin um
anyway so long as we they they they kind
of keep us on our toes I think that's
fine but don't let them spoil our fun
don't I'm going to finish even prompt on
the bloke of course um do not let you
feel that you've somehow been a moral
failure you know if you've done some
naughty linguistic bit of uh you or I up
there that what we're going to do is
keep language constantly on its toes
doing different things drawing new
distinctions I don't care if I talk
about issues or problems I'm wanting to
refresh what we're talking about not
leave it in the same blasted dark hole
thank you very much you're voting
no so the next stage of our debate will
involve all of you but before we throw
things open to the floor I will
reveal the vote everybody voted as they
came in uh and so before the
debate we had for the motion a pretty
resounding
53% which doesn't entirely surprise me I
have to say and against the
motion a respectable 27% but with a
crucial swing to
20% don't know so I don't want any
untorn ballots at the end of this when
we take um the votes again make a
decision so now we have um microphones I
think going around and what I'm going to
do so we get the most um kind of good
conversation is I'm going to collect two
or three questions and please keep your
questions brief and you can direct them
um to all of the panelists to a panel
panelist in particular um let's have one
at the front right here and wait till
you have the microphone to speak
please um can you hear me yeah I used to
teach English to foreigners in London I
Was preparing them for important exams
and possibly jobs using
English they used to say sometimes but
my land lady says you was my land lady
says I ain't got n
what according to um the panel should I
have replied okay so that's our one
let's take another question Oliver Cal
spoke with such conviction that just for
a moment it occurred to me he might
conceivably be right but then I came to
my
senses surely the point is this when a
man say is speaking to somebody he wants
the person to whom he is speaking to
understand what he means if he then uses
disinterested and uninterested at random
it depends on the context but the
listener may very well not understand
what he means now to use Mary Beard's
expression I don't think that's fun and
interesting I think it's just plain
silly let's have let's have one more
before we speak um I am tempted to vote
in favor of the motion uh which is that
English has gone to the dogs and not
least because of something that I heard
on the Today program this morning which
made me choke on my cornflakes which was
when Evan Davis of all people um said
that uh people who were relying on the
savings interest for their income were
screwed uh which was a a rather unusual
word to hear at that time in the morning
on Radio 4 so um the language if I'm
going to make a decision in this debate
I would like to know from the panelists
uh something to do with that little sign
on the screen which is a hashtag what do
the panelists think has been the effect
of Twitter on the English language okay
so now we have the I would say our three
do we listen to our land
ladies um is uh being a stickler about
these things really just being silly and
what is Twitter doing to the English
language are you looking at me why not
all right well but but I first have to
make a very very very important point in
relation to what Mary said she accused
me of being a an English grumpy old man
Mary I'm
Welsh the the rest of the description I
accept with
pride uh L with the land lady but that's
the point isn't it you making such an
important point there if she continues
if your students had continued to use
that sort of of usage they would not
well they wouldn't have passed any exams
in the that's for sure but they wouldn't
have been able to communicate as clearly
as they otherwise might have done and
that's it that's what it's all about and
all the stuff that Mary's given she
knows it's nonsense you could see the
way she was delivering it she knows not
and whereas Oliver was absolutely
brilliant I mean I didn't understand I
what he said but that's not the point
and he is he is very clever and by God
did he speak beautiful English so he's
also learned as well I mean that's
that's the point Twitter I don't do it
um I don't have any objection to it at
all uh does it enrich the language
probably not but it's a fat isn't it
it'll come and go interestingly um my
14-year-old nearly 14-year-old doesn't
tweet um and neither does any of his
friends they all use BBM on different
sorts of messaging service so I wonder
whether it's going to continue I don't
know perhaps it will um and um The Well
exactly exactly what what an important
distinction that that there the yeah of
course we can lose words of course we
can and nobody is going to suddenly wake
up on Thursday say my God that that word
we we had doesn't exist any long so I
can't possibly use it again it it
doesn't work like that but gradually
there is an accretion of these things
and the more the more words we lose the
poorer our language becomes and what I
want to do that is a bit silly of course
it is but what I want to do is to
preserve and protect the wonderful
language that we have and all this stuff
about Latin I mean of course Latin is
all rubbish but the the we we have a
beautiful expressive language beautiful
in art beautiful in every conceivable
sense when it's used properly and we
know when it's being used properly don't
we that's what it comes down to and all
I want to do is preserve it and protect
it change it of course all the time
endlessly it's Dynamic but let let's
hold on let's not cliche coming up sorry
Simon let's not Chuck out the baby with
a bath water sorry I like Oliver would
like to add I think yes let me deal with
your point first Madam you should say to
the students that English has many
dialects and many registers you use
different forms of English in different
contexts and if the foreign students
whom you're talking to are applying for
a job for example they need to master
the register of Standard English as it
is written and as it is spoken but that
isn't in inverted comma proper English
which John has said several times now
using English properly that's a
particular form of English it's Standard
English and I referred earlier to the um
abolition not as a conscious decision
but as a falling into disuse of
instruction in grammar in schools around
the 1960s and it was a good thing
because the content of those lessons was
rubbish but it was a bad thing that
nothing replaced them until much more
recently an English language is taught
well in schools now every August you get
scares about declining standards of
literacy it's not true there is a
persistent problem with people
particularly in the labor market who
can't use language fluently but that's
nothing to do with declining standards
of literacy and you would you should say
to the to to to the young people that
you talk to who learn English as a
foreign language um Master the language
in different registers um because you
can use it in different ways in
different context and I'll use the word
situation in different situations second
question referring to the distinction
between disinterested and
uninterested you answered your own
question sir when you said you can tell
from the context that's the thing that
the sticklers never look at how do I
know when Simon heer uses the word
Wicked that he doesn't mean it as a term
of approbation I
[Laughter]
[Applause]
know well
Wicked I know from the context and yes
the use of disinterested to mean bored
is doubtless originally a misconception
but it exists and we use the word
interest in dual or indeed multiple
senses but we don't we don't confuse it
because we know from the context and
that's what the sticklers don't grasp on
the question of Twitter um Twitter uh
and texting and other technological
innovations they're not debasing the
language relax people said exactly the
same thing they said exactly the same
thing about the invention of the
telegraph uh Twitter is a way of
communicating that I find fresh and
vital and sometimes um a distinct
Improvement on the sort of Pros that you
might have found let's say in a times
leading article a century
ago we'll have some more questions and
then let can I give you a little po is
that allowed very short Mary Mary had a
mobile she tweeted day and night but
when it came to her exam she'd forgotten
how to
write I think Mary would like to add
something I I I must add something
because I've been you know slightly
troduced to the other end and I'm I'm
going say I am this is using a bit of
ciceronian um rhetoric I am not going to
ask Mr Humphries to um comment on
whether the Welsh language is going to
the dogs but I'm sure there's an
interesting comparanda
there um I think can I just say about
this disinterested and uninterested see
that the question really is not whether
we can put which words we're going to
put in the zoo or put the preservation
order on or make kind of endangered
species that will be you know specially
m in um in order to make sure they've
got some you know some suitable
Offspring the question is what are the
distinctions we want to draw what do we
want to you what what are the
distinctions and the differences that we
want our language to help us point up
now if the case were that all we were
doing was making crudder and crudder
distinctions then I might say well look
there there might be a problem here with
the language but I don't think I as all
of us saying it's partly about context
it's partly about we have different ways
of representing the distinction that we
once used to represent as disinterested
and uninterested it isn't that we've
given up on that uh we just do it
differently thank you know in some ways
that's that's fine by me I'm interested
in the distinction and the arguments not
the actual words that go with them
that's why with Twitter I think you I
think all of us right about the language
I think the problem with Twitter is what
it's doing to arguments and that might
be that might be something different I
don't think it's ruining the English
language very good and I'm we have
question from the top yes speaking as
someone who's married to an
American and who's come this evening
with a second American uh I'd like to
ask the panelists do you agree that it's
mostly the fault of the
Yanks okay well we're going to really
hang on to that question because it
obviously must be addressed um I'd like
to challenge something Oliver said just
now about teaching in schools and about
Rising um the the safety of Standards
I'm I've been an A- level an IB examiner
and a few years ago I was invited to
write some material for hans's for AEV
material and I submitted stuff and I was
told it was too difficult and I said
well this is what I the standard I
marked to with a levels and IB are you
telling me that a level standards in
this country are going down and she said
yes okay
and one more over
here I'd like to ask John hrey if he
could share with us the his
understanding of the word
[Applause]
[Music]
impartial and if it happens to be the
same as the one we all read in the
dictionary could he explain to us how
the left leading language that is
increasingly coming out of the BBC is is
consistent with its Charter
obligation to be impartial in other
words is it the BBC or the language
going to the
dogs well we'll see where we get let's
take one more question at the top yeah
um I'd like to ask a question to the
opposition who I feel are maybe a little
too idealistic um I'm an English teacher
in an inner city school and I can assure
you that if you came into some of our
lessons with our lower ability student
students you would think that the
English language was going to the dogs
um and I suppose my point is that we
need to be it's it becomes very
difficult when people high-profile
people in public life who speak very
eloquently and very beautifully and very
clearly as you two both did in your
speeches then say that it actually
doesn't matter how you use language
because I think that's that's too
confusing for our students we need to um
emphasize that there is a right and a
and a correct way to speak and write and
once you've mastered that then you can
use language any way you like but until
you have there is there is a correct way
and we all need to be clear on
that so so we have the fault of the
Yanks a level standards going down again
another important question about schools
how we teach in schools and then perhaps
we can come back to impartiality so
Simon you haven't well I I wouldn't
dream of uh trespassing on John's
territory but he will give you he will
give you a definition of what his
interested means in terms of the BBC
when he speaks um some of these other
questions seem to melt into each other I
don't think it's the fault of the Yanks
at all America has a is a distinct
country it's a distinct culture it has a
distinct language which occasionally
Bears a resemblance to ours um
and I wouldn't presume to uh judge uh
how Americans speak and write it I think
it's a fault of the education system
there was a distressing story in the
paper today I think I read it in
Oliver's paper so it must be true um it
said that people who have English as a
second language have a much higher
chance of getting a job straight from
school University uh than people uh who
have English as a first language and it
singled out
um the the usual whipping boys the white
working class in our country who uh are
apparently neglected by the education
system and these people have been
terribly betrayed I remember John in uh
August about 10 years ago on the Today
program interviewing two examiners from
the GCSE board um to and asking them
what it took to get pass in English and
math I'm sure John remembers this
interview and the two exam The Examiner
in English uh admitted after under heavy
questioning from John in a very
disinterested way
that uh that with without being able to
spell or even write properly you could
pass uh English language GCSE I went
into a really good comprehensive School
uh three years ago when my book was
published and met some of the six
formers there the Headmaster who was a
very fine man who told me he wrote books
for teachers who teach English in
schools assured me that spelling
mistakes and grammatical errors were
corrected right across the curriculum in
his school uh because he knew how
dangerous it was to let his pupils out
at the age of 16 or 18 uh without a
proper command of the English language
when I asked the six form uh what their
experience was of their teachers
correcting uh these things in biology or
history or geography they said none of
them did and the Headmaster was there
and put his head in his hands and I
don't know who got beaten up later
whether it was him or the or the or the
teacher or or the teachers or the pupils
I think there are terrible problems in
our school we seem to be very reluctant
to make people learn a language
rigorously as I said in the way that the
French or the Germans do um we need to
be realistic and shape our young people
for the world in which they're going to
live not the world in which we would
like them to live and unfortunately we
we live in a world where the minute an
Englishman or English woman opens their
mouths there was a grammatical error for
you um where they are judged by what
they say and how they've said it and I
wish it wasn't like that but it is and
it will continue to be like that without
any help from people like me or John
humph and so we had better start saying
to people if you wish to be treated as
an educated person you have to become an
educated person in terms of using the
language and that is something that
schools I think are graphically failing
our young people in at the moment
Oliver
the question is it the fault of the
Yanks as you put it said no of course
not um there is a
widespread supposition or a
Prejudice that you hear in language
debates in this country and I'll single
out one particular culprit Prince
Charles um there's a widespread
supposition that the American dialect is
a debased form of English uh it isn't
both the dialect I
speak and the dialect that um uh that
that uh that my American equivalents
would speak let's say a columnist on the
New York Times would speak um they are
not neither is pure English they are
descendants of a common ancestor and in
many respects the American dialect is
closer to that common ancestor than my
own dialect um for example if you listen
to Erica she will doubtless pronounce
the r in labor party whereas I won't um
in that respect the American dialect is
closer to history than my own they're
just different ways of expressing
English they're not a corruption um
they're not a they're not a debasement
they're just dialects and there's
nothing correct or incorrect about a
dialect it's just something we pick up
on the question of um education I take
very serious indeed
the stubborn problem as I said that some
people in schools and in the labor
market don't have basic literary skills
it's not a new problem um and I
simply uh I simply don't recognize in
your depiction of the argument that Mary
and I put anything that we actually said
we didn't say it doesn't matter how you
speak we said on the contrary it matters
very much that you be fluent or your
students be fluent in the conventions
Standard English because that is how
you're judged but what I take strongest
you with is the idea that this is proper
English or correct English as opposed to
let's say the dialect that Erica speaks
um these are not rules of grammar they
are conventions of
orthography and conventions of certain
semantic distinctions um they are
important to learn but I totally
disagree with the idea that there is is
an inviable correct way of putting it
and that you're somehow and the language
that the sticklers use is quite
apocalyptic that you're somehow
barbarous or illiterate if you don't
know them if you're unfamiliar with them
if you have to be taught them that's a
distinction between rules of grammar
that are instinctive and conventions of
usage that are
taught I I feel I I should say that
obviously I I do not think this is where
I will show my colors in this debate
um that it's all the fault of the Yanks
and that American English is debat I is
debased I have to say I'm married to an
Englishman there is some confusion in
our house about what we mean by pants
but we manage we I also think we have to
just watch Dr he for a bit with his
admiration of the French education
system you know somehow we've been led
to believe that the French have got it
all right they teach grammar and he's
about to say the taxi drivers quote
voler because that's what usually comes
next taxi drivers taxi drivers know one
quotation from voler which they use
every time actually at uh you know the
underbelly of the French education
system is no better at doing what Simon
thinks thinks wrongly he wants uh than
ours is probably that's fine but I don't
think we ought to think you know that on
one issue only you can go across the
channel and find they've got it right Dr
heer because I don't think they
have let's have some do I he did
attacked the BBC after oh yes he did so
I mean I don't have to speak I can no go
I incidentally I do congratulate um
Oliver on on on that wonderful
construction of straw man If Ever I want
a straw man built in my garden scare
away the crows I'm going to call on you
because we didn't say anything anyway
whatever let let let let others let
others judge that um imp partiality I
think the questioner knows precisely
what it of course he knows exactly what
it is um it's what he's getting at is is
this notion that he Al is festering away
in his mind that um the BBC is partial
uh first of all the BBC is not
monolithic so therefore it is not
partial there are those people who work
for it who take one view there are those
people who work for it who take another
view um but you asked you made it rather
more personal than that and you asked me
about my imp
partiality all I can tell you sir is
that I've been doing this job on the
Today program for 27 years and I have
been accused by all of
them of
being unfair to all of them and I hope
that continues cuz I mean I know it's
it's it's it's it's a rather crude and
clumsy way of measuring impartiality
isn't it but uh but I reckon you know if
if um one moment you're being being uh
attacked by the labor party um by the
conservative party rather poisoning The
Well of democratic debate which is what
a certain Jonathan Aken who subsequently
went to jail but we'll put that to one
side said said said about me and uh and
then and and praised by the party
simultaneous simultaneously for for
saving democracy on behalf of a grateful
nation and then when the labor party
came to power all of a sudden you find
that actually as they said in the left
of BBC something must be done about the
John humphy problem I mean you know
that's the way it's it's politics for
God's sake and you should be old enough
and ugly enough to know that and I would
as as for whether it's the fault of the
BBC or not and obviously you think it is
the fault of the BBC whatever the fault
happens to be all I would say i' be
entirely serious here I put aside what
the today program does some people like
it some don't um the BBC is I believe
immensely important to this country I
struggle to imagine this country country
without the BBC for all its many many
many faults I think it's a great
civilizing institution and I hope it
survive um I've changed my first
language about four four times I'm
getting back to English now I'm trying
to understand what you're talking
about um two words come to my mind are
that of context and communication
because I've worked in many foreign
countries and one has to simplify one's
language so if you say disinterested or
uninterested to a Kenyon it's basically
the word interested with something
vaguely negative in front of it and
that's as far as you get and I think
that's important if I'm talking to my
landl lady and I use very correct
English you'll probably think I'm Posh
and I won't be communicating anything
much to her anyway I think there is that
point about somebody up there was saying
about learning the tools of the trade
before you become a Picasso of language
but I do do think we are in a situation
where partly because of
internationalization I'm at War
University we're at least half the
student of foreign um inter
internationalization is one thing
language becoming abstract is another
and I think young people in particular
using simplified forms of communication
like
Twitter does pose a risk because it
means there are less and less people
less and less environments which are
able to use English in a creative way
and flexible changing adaptive way okay
next comment right next to you I
think a lot has been uh the BBC is
referred to quite a lot what's Curious
in this whole conversation is that class
and English hasn't been raised once and
when one thinks of the BBC one of the
most important historical things they
did was develop a thing of called
received and correct pronunciation
spelling whatever and when I was growing
up I grew up in at Yorkshire and you
know looking at the English language is
going to the dogs I wouldn't find
anybody in the street who wouldn't say
the English language is going to dogs
there wouldn't there wouldn't be the and
I was told Michael if you want to get on
in life I don't think you should do it
like that you know and so the
relationship of language which my
grandparents were speaking broad
Yorkshire and advancement in British
Society was codified by language and it
was important to realize that until the
1950s workingclass voices weren't
allowed on the BBC that actors had to
play the part of workingclass voices
that people like in movies Dicky atenor
and John Mills had to go down Market to
adopt language so they could be engineer
in the bottom of a sorry I'm just going
to wrap you up so it's I just want to
I'd like actually a comment really from
the panel because interestingly the all
of this has been spoken in language
which I speak which is a kind of
obviously a middle class English
language which I was taught
what do they feel is the role of class
in the whole organization of British
language which after all for many many
years wasn't written down and was spoken
regionally yeah do we have anyone
there's someone at the back you have to
I think come to the
microphone here I think this one's for
Simon really um he's because I feel I
should defend professional linguists I I
read a couple of the reviews of his book
which he said uh they said was less fair
and you should just have there are no
rules at all that wasn't at all what
they were saying but certainly Jeff
pulam who was one of the professional
linguists and David Crystal what they
were saying was there are very very
clear rules of English and you got them
completely wrong um so I was just
suppose the question is did you read the
reviews at all or did you just decide
that anyone who thinks anyone who thinks
that we should be describing the rules
of language is a is a less a fair
liberal do good okay so we have three we
have the isue of inter internationalism
a very interesting issue of class which
indeed we haven't discussed
and who gets to discuss and make the
rules Simon do you want to start uh I
did read the reviews and I thought they
were
wrong since you asked and I think it's
all very well for people like David
Crystal and the other chat whose name I
can't even remember uh to to go on
talking about and they did talk in those
reviews about uh being unduly censorious
let them try and get a job without
speaking English properly put themselves
in the place of a 16 or 18 year old uh
young person who is patronized this goes
back to the class question who's
patronized by an employer uh because he
or she turns up and doesn't speak
English in the way that the employer
would like the employer might say well
I'd be embarrassed for that person to
meet my customers or to write letters to
them we've all had letters from
institutions from banks that are badly
written and and are full of errors and
we throw them away because we don't take
them seriously at least I do and I think
if you want to be taken seriously if you
want to have um to use a gly jargon word
a good interface with the public you
should at least respect the public by
speaking English properly um class is
important this is what I this is what I
meant by saying um we shouldn't be
looking for a society that we wish
existed we have to accept the society
that does exist and I regret that you
know in 1940 Wilfred pickles became the
first person to speak with a regional
accent uh on the BBC he was put on the
BBC because it was believed that his
thick Yorkshire accent would be
incomprehensible to Germans who were
listening
in
we have fortunately moved on from uh
from from such a time and I I can't
imagine anybody's going to criticize
anyone these days for speaking English
with a certain accent uh however it's
the grammatical forms within what they
are saying and the correct use of words
will remain important and in my view so
it should Oliver um Simon you dismiss
the critical reviews the gentleman whose
name you affect not to remember is Jeff
pulm who's professor of linguistics at
Edinburgh um and you say in your book
which I have read that you have respect
for the work of descriptive linguists
and you can't say that Simon because you
disagree fundamentally with their
premise that English is not a set of
edicts there's not a set body of rules
out there um the lunatics are in charge
of the Asylum language is set the rules
are set by General usage in the words of
um Horus the Roman poet
um Norma lendi the the custom of
speaking William sappire the New York
Times columnist wrote a book called in
love with Norma lendi uh which he didn't
really follow he was more of a stickler
than that but I am in love with Norma
lendi and I'm faithful to Norma lendi
and I urge you to be faithful to normal
lendi because language is set not by an
external body of rules but by the custom
of usage certainly one can take a view
on particular constructions we heard
from John earlier about the question of
terrorists on which I actually agree
with him um or the feminist objection to
the term chairman or the use of he which
Simon did as a as a generic pronoun
these are valid objections but I don't
see how one can plausibly object to
particular grammatical constructions
that are have historical and literary
precedent and are in General usage as
wrong on the question of class that's a
very important point and the earliest
gramar uh grammar sticklers Robert Baker
in the 1760s specifically criticized the
the the pance of what he call low people
which were servants and actors and
Fowler a much much better writer than
almost all his imitators um HW Fowler um
uh took examples deliberately from our
profession journalists to illustrate
solic isms and errors as saw them he was
a moralizer too they're all wrong
they're all wrong because they
understate they underestimate the
importance of General usage in the
construction of linguistic rules can I
just say by the way that it is possible
to respect somebody without agreeing
with them which is exactly all of how I
feel about
you
Mary I was interested in you know Simon
view about whether you give people a job
or not because I've for quite different
reasons I've spent the few hours this
last week looking at YouTube clips from
the BBC in the 50s 60s and' 70s and you
know what we've been saying is
absolutely right they talk in a way that
you would not now associate I mean you
know it makes Prince Charles look plean
is the ABS and you think I'd never give
any of them a job I mean there's are a
complete load of barking toughs though
presumably some of this was stuff the
tonight program in the 1960s that I
watched and presumably I didn't sit
there and think you what a load of
barking TOS I I must have thought this
was normal at that point so the change
is extremely quick no absolutely right
my one of my many huge mistakes um
during my um 51 years at the BBC was
that um about I know 25 years ago no
more than that 30 years ago my then
editor I was reading the television news
um took me aside one day and said um can
you take a chap called John put a chap
called John Cole through his Paces in
the studio to see if he's any good in
front of a television camera because
he's the political editor of the
Observer and he wants to become the
BBC's political editor so I did and uh
we spent the afternoon me and John in
the studio John and I in the studio and
um and and I went back to my editor and
I said no way I mean can't understand a
word he says his Northern Irish accident
so and mercifully happily they ignored
me and gave John the job and he became
one of our greatest and Best Loved
political editors and what a colossal
error the fact of course he had a very
thick broad Northern Ireland act in fact
I once very I tell this very quickly we
uh we were at a uh Party Conference
together once and I had done a
pre-recorded interview with him for the
9:00 news which we had to edit down
because it was too long and he and I and
the the edit of the program sat there in
the edit Suite um playing the thing back
to I which what we could cut out of it
and John said forgive me I can't do the
accent but I'll try he said could you
play it again and I did we played it
again he listened very carefully con he
said could you play it again and we did
three times and the clock was scking
away it was coming to 9:00 we were due
on air in a few minutes I said John
what's the matter and he said just let
it there I can't understand what I was
saying it it did not justify my original
condem of him but there we are but I
tell you I had to read what Mary is so
right when I joined I came from I come
from place called spotting cardic where
where you have to have a kind of coat
hanger inserted in your mouth to speak
properly and I grew talking like that
you know what I mean a kid that was how
I talked and then I joined to BC and
they say we can't have you talking like
that can we so what they did was they
sent me to America and I learned to talk
properly
there well I think that that comment
actually uh reveals the the gamut of how
the English language is made I think at
this point um I'm afraid it's time
you're going to have to vote again now
remember you have
your cards for and
against I urge you not to remain
undecided and as you do that we will
have our closing speeches in reverse
order so vote quietly please and welcome
we're just going to do it from our
places so Mary will start just got time
if if you're hesitating to vote no um Mr
harri has just said he agreed with me
I'm sure he means on most things and I
think we're really pretty close so a no
vote would go down well if you're uh
wondering what to do I think the reason
for giving a no vote has to be first you
know nobody certainly not either Oliver
or myself is that right uh
has ever suggested
the language rules are for throwing away
you know there is no human social
interaction that is not bound by rules
language goes with that they are
important what what we're in a sense
wanting you to embrace is ideas of
change that some of us slightly more
middle-aged guys occasionally feel
anxious about but we've talked about the
use of language and vocabulary in
particular I just wanted to leave you
with two examples of where in my
lifetime I have seen vocabulary change
in ways that might be decried but are
really important indicators of changing
social values one would be how you refer
to people of color blacks or Negroes I
was brought up never to say black that
was extremely rude you had to say negro
imagine going out and doing that and the
other of course is in relation to the
gay movement and whether you can say
homosexual queer gay I was likewise
taught never ever to say queer and now I
discover there is a whole intellectual
discipline of queer studies now those
are not mad random changes done by
people on their iPhones those are
instances of language changing to help
us say new things very good rest
my
Simon John and I were told before we
came in here that um most most of you
would have voted by the time Mary
finished and so I wasn't entirely sure
what use I or he or NE Oliver can be and
I'm very much inclined to sit here for
the next couple of minutes and say how
much I wish I could take part in the
Milton versus Shakespeare debate
um
in favor of course of of of of Milton
who is our greatest poet I I wanted to
say two things really uh when you're
when you're voting those two or three of
you haven't yet voted think about our
young people and think about giving them
the best possible chance to survive in a
world that's incredibly unpleasant and
very difficult and uh one that I would
not I would not want to be a young
person again now it's a much more brutal
and competitive life leaving school
leaving University and getting into the
real world than it ever was when we were
younger thank thank you baby boomers for
sorting that one out and it's important
to equip our young people with proper
skills so that they can be taken
seriously and respected I also think
that it's important to bear in mind the
Aesthetics of beautifully spoken and
written English if you went to a concert
a Symphony concert uh to hear um
Schubert's great C major and it was
played in uh in B flat minor you would
wonder what on Earth was going on and I
I I think there is a certain parallel
there my final appeal because I think
you now all have voted uh is to anyone
here who has any influence over the
school curriculum I think Oliver is
right actually I'll say this now you V I
think he's right to say that grammar
lessons as I understand them uh were
fatuous and Ill informed and based on
people who were um Prejudiced and stupid
and who made very bad decisions like
Bishop L about the language I think in
fact it was Bishop L who first had the
Prejudice in the 1760s against splitting
the infinitive uh but what I would like
to see is a compulsory teaching from a
very early age of a foreign language
because I think there's no better way of
making people young people children
learn grammar and learn what the meaning
of words is and how words can be used
precisely then by making them learn as
early as possible a foreign language and
if we want to have language as a badge
of civilization and also as a means of
acquiring the trappings of civilization
teaching foreign languages to children
as early as possible I think is the best
way of doing
it
Oliver Simon I hate to sound
pantic
but
I'm I'm certain that Bishop BL had no uh
prohibition against the split infinitive
I would date that bogus fatuous
pointless rule that still people write
to uh about they write the times about I
would date that from the 1830s Milton I
admire too and he referred to the
serpent as the subtlest Beast of all the
field ladies and gentlemen do you know
how he spelled suest he spelled it s u t
l
s everybody did then it was some
busybody pedant later on who decided
that subtle needed to have some
reference to the Original Latin so
inserted a b these things are purely
accidental
there's not an obviously right way of
spelling the word there are conventions
of orthography there are conventions of
usage that's what Mary and I are arguing
language is absolutely fascinating and
language has rules language has rules
and there is an instinct for learning a
set of rules which is then applied but
we're not talking about that we're
talking about some impossibly narrow set
of prejudices recall how often the word
disinterested has been raised in this
debate and wonder wonder why people get
so upset about it the very fact that
it's mentioned so often shows that it
isn't endangered and if there's one
language in the world that isn't at risk
of perishing it is the language that we
are speaking gentlemen get a
grip
and above all do not disdain as Simon
actually does in his writings as he
explicitly does do not disdain the
evidence of usage usage General usage
not anyone's usage not anyone's solic
ISM not a misprint in the times or the
daily mail or the telegraph but General
usage is the only evidence we have for
the content of the English language
which Mary and I relish and cherish
quite as much as our
[Applause]
opponents it's been a a really bizarre
debate this hasn't it
because I knew that I'd be able to pray
my opponents our opponents in Aid
because I knew that they would be
perfectly articulate and use wonderful
language which of course they've done
but they've also agreed with us on
almost every single point I've been
making copious notes as is my and I
can't find anything really with which I
disagree it's quite extraordinary when I
um wrote my first book and and the first
reviews appeared on Amazon I was accused
in it might have even been the very
first one of being a pedant actually I
wasn't accused of being a pedant I was
accused of being a pendant
which I thought to this day I'm not sure
whether it was deliberate or and and of
course he was exactly right he it wasn't
he was exactly right cuz I do swing from
side to side and and and and and of and
of of course they're right of course
language changes and thank God for that
as both Simon and I have made very very
clear over and over again during the
course of evening of course language
changes but look one of my uh former
editors on the day is a chat called Rod
little and and uh Rod is I think you
could safely say a controversialist or
whatever the right word is you You' read
no doubt and um if you think something
he will find a way disagreeing with you
and he does it brilliantly and cleverly
and when the language debate began a
while back again it it props up from
time to time doesn't it and it it
happened I don't know 10 years ago it
might have been and Rod in a column in
the times not the Sunday Times then in a
column in the times set out to prove
that that the course grammar was going P
his punctuation was ridiculous who
needed it and he wrote a column a 1200w
column for the Times without any
punctuation at all to prove that we
would indeed be able to understand what
he was saying and it's true I did
understand it but it took me the best
part of Saturday morning to do so
because I had to read it over and over
and over again to work out quite what he
meant and that's the point I want
English and forgive me Oliver but I'm
going to use the word unambiguous again
I want English to be capable of being
spoken and written unambiguously if that
is what we want we sometimes seek
ambiguity but mostly we don't I want it
to be spoken and written clearly and we
have the wherewithal to do that I don't
want us to lose that wherewith all
that's all and there are some
disturbing Tremors perhaps that suggest
people are losing interest not becoming
disinterested are becoming uninterested
in this topic that's why it's wonderful
that we're doing it tonight and to see
so many of you here is absolutely
heartwarming and knowing with absolute
certainty that you're going to support
the position that Simon and I have taken
I can't thank you enough thanks
we have a few more minutes while we're
just waiting anxiously for our um can we
take a couple more questions while we
wait yeah I think we have over on this
side
yeah um has the BBC ever done a survey
as to whether the public would prefer to
receive received English as it is spoken
rather than what I I can't understand
half of what is said now I mean you
listen to poor Evan Davis I mean can
Perhaps Perhaps Oliver could go and give
him some lessons because they don't
complete their sentences they speak too
fast it's so many people say this I'm
not
alone I've given up TR listening to him
at 7:30 in the morning when you're still
half asleep it's not
possible and we do get a lot of
complaints about that it's true over
here at the front but I think on your
question can I just answer that very
quick Point um we do we have done
surveys about whether they prefer us the
audience would prefers to go back to
receive pronunciation and the answer is
absolutely no they they like the um
Regional accents that we have and anyway
it would be Preposterous wouldn't it to
to to try to impose RP on all of us all
of
us I think at the back first and then at
the front so uh John and Simon is there
any example of egregious abuse of the
English language that you're forced to
admit you rather glad exists and uh
Oliver and Mary are there any abuses of
the English language that you really
wish just had never been given life and
then we have we have one more question
before we yeah right here at the
front right here oh sorry sorry I realiz
the microphone language is power and to
label people as speaking incorrectly
does disempower them to some degree
degree um I wonder to what extent you
thought that labeling people speaking
incorrectly was an attempt by The
Establishment to continue to exclude
people from legitimacy in some respect
because
um just because you know speaking
correctly as soon as sort of is valid by
The
Establishment okay so validation by The
Establishment um in imposing speaking
correctly um we've addressed I think
bring back uh
RP um go ahead yeah um your question
Madam gives me a perfect opportunity for
a gratuitous attack on one of Simon's
Heroes um in his book which I've read um
minutely Simon refers to one of his
Saints uses the word Saints in the
question of style as Enoch Powell um
Enoch Powell uh was a sophist and a
crank on every issue leave aside Simon
said says um whatever the occasional
controversies of his politics he was a
splendid stylist which is some euphemism
uh and I admire Simon for coining by
toties rather than
you the the the problem with Enoch how
intellectually was that he wasn't a
stylist he was a furious pedant he was a
sophist um and I do think there is a
great deal in what you say about um
delegitimizing forms of speech and
revers to a certain type of reasoning
never mind language that has nothing to
do with the sort of values that we
should want to convey uh
now can I just um answer the question
about the abuses of language because I I
think actually um it's what again going
back to my Twitter point it's it's more
the abuse of argument or the use of
cliche which I despise and I think that
doesn't separate either of us you know
so you know I think I would be very
pleased if uh the today program before
ministers went on it said I'm afraid we
don't use the phrase hardworking
families on this program any longer you
try that you know and or or had you know
had an Erica of little bell that every
time they said hardw workking know but
but that I think isn't about language so
much is it's about uh the the the the
act the flaccidity of the arguments that
these people are trying to make using
language and that's different are there
any things that you are forced to admit
abuses of language on my own part yes
well you were I'm asking I'm reminding
how how long have we got no no no that
you would that you would actually
reluctantly admire that I reluctantly
admire yes or use abuses of the English
Lang well it it it
is it's what kids do I like their abuses
is that the right word for what they do
to the English language if it is I love
it I enjoy it I find it entertaining so
long as I know that they are also going
to be able when they need to to speak a
different kind of English the kind of
English that will able them to do all
those things that Simon was talking
about but but of course I we we had
somebody on the other day who um a
regional a very very very strong
Regional act and some people struggle to
hear it understand what she was saying
some complained afterwards but she she
delivered it with such style she
happened to be 94 that's immaterial she
delivered it with such style and Panache
and Verve and enjoyment that we all
enjoyed just listen the music of her
language was wonderful even though we
couldn't quite understand what she was
saying I'll settle for that well ladies
and
gentlemen the results are
in so a little reminder that before the
debate there were 53% of you for the
motion that the English language is
going to the dogs 27 were against and
there was a don't know a possible swing
of
20% after the
debate
57% are for so even more
strongly but and against the motion 41
[Applause]
% so the motion have won but against
have definitely won the swing so well
done to
everyone what was
[Applause]
the